Kelsay Irby isn't somebody who likes being in the spotlight-- in fact, kind of the opposite. And she wasn't looking to get in the newspaper the night that she did the thing that got her national attention. She was just showing up to work like normal at the emergency room at a hospital an hour or so outside Seattle, St. Michael's Medical Center.
Kelsay Irby并不是一个喜欢成为焦点的人——事实上，恰恰相反。在她做出那件让她受到全国关注的事情的那天晚上，她并没有打算上报纸。她只是像往常一样来到西雅图郊外大约一小时车程的一家医院——圣迈克尔医疗中心的急诊室上班。
So that night when I came in at 7:00, I was looking at the number of patients that were there, which was high.
那天晚上我7点上班时，我看到那里的病人数量很多，非常多。
Like really high. People were all over the lobby in a messy chaos, sitting in wheelchairs because there weren't enough regular chairs, sitting on the floor, sick kids and their parents, ambulance crews with patients waiting to be seen. Kelsay says it was like an airport gate where the flight's just been canceled. A lot of dissatisfaction, a lot of unrest. And she was short-staffed. Kelsay is the charge nurse. So it's her job to make sure all these patients get seen and that she has enough staff to do that, which has been a problem since COVID at hospitals all over the country, hers included.
真的非常多。大厅里乱作一团，因为没有足够的椅子，人们坐在轮椅上，坐在地板上，有生病的孩子和他们的父母，还有救护人员带着病人等待就诊。Kelsay说这就像航班刚刚被取消的机场登机口。有很多不满，有很多不安。而且她的人手不足。Kelsay是主管护士。所以她的工作是确保所有这些病人都得到诊治，并且她有足够的员工来做这件事，这自新冠疫情以来在全国各地的医院（包括她所在的医院）都是一个问题。
So many nurses burned out and left the profession since COVID that it's left hospitals perpetually short-staffed, which, Kelsay points out, makes the job that much more stressful for the nurses who stayed and leads to more of them saying that they can't take it, throwing in the towel, making the problem worse. The people who run Kelsay's hospitals say their staffing levels are in line with national standards and best practices. But Kelsay says, typically, she only has half the nurses she should have for the night shift-- half.
自新冠疫情以来，这么多护士精疲力竭离开了这个行业，导致医院长期人手短缺，正如Kelsay所指出的，这让留下来的护士工作压力大得多，导致更多的人说他们受不了了，选择辞职，使问题变得更糟。管理Kelsay所在医院的人表示，他们的员工配备水平符合国家标准和最佳实践。但Kelsay说，通常情况下，她夜班的护士人数只有应有的一半——只有一半。
So I was already short-staffed. And then I was going to be two more down. Two of my 7:00 nurses had called in sick.
所以我本来就人手不足。然后我还要再少两个人。我的两名7点上班的护士请了病假。
And if that weren't enough, they'd had a cyberattack. This was a ransomware attack this past October at one of the largest nonprofit hospital chains in the country. CommonSpirit Health, which meant that, suddenly, they couldn't access patients' medical records on the computer for two weeks.
如果这还不够糟糕的话，他们还遭遇了网络攻击。这是去年十月发生在该国最大的非营利医院连锁店之一CommonSpirit Health的一次勒索软件攻击，这意味着他们突然有两周时间无法在电脑上访问病人的医疗记录。
I cannot overstate how chaotic that made things and how much it slowed us down.
我无法形容这让事情变得多么混乱，也无法形容这拖慢了我们多少进度。
Normally she keeps track of everybody in the lobby by opening their charts in the computer where she can see if they have lab results yet and get the basic information to figure out who can wait longer and who needs care right away.
通常，她会通过在电脑上打开病人的图表来记录大厅里的每一个人，在那里她可以看到他们是否已经有了化验结果，并获取基本信息来判断谁可以等更久，谁需要立即接受治疗。
And I can see if I need to keep my eye on this patient, or this patient came in for chest pain, but they got punched in the chest by their brother. You know, chances are that it's probably not a heart attack. But because we didn't have our computer system, I wasn't able to see anything other than just "chest pain." Yeah, so--
我可以看看我是否需要密切关注这位病人，或者这位病人是因为胸痛进来的，但他们被兄弟打了胸口。你知道，很有可能那不是心脏病发作。但因为我们没有电脑系统，除了“胸痛”之外，我什么都看不到。是的，所以——
Wow.
哇。
And I couldn't see vital signs. I couldn't see labs. I couldn't see anything about the patient's history. That is very much like a pilot, you know, flying without instruments in a foggy, stormy night.
我看不到生命体征。我看不到化验结果。我无法查看关于病人病史的任何信息。这就像一位飞行员在雾蒙蒙、暴风雨的夜晚不看仪表飞行。
I can't tell as you describe this-- I can't tell, like, is this just a really bad night? Or is this like the worst you'd ever seen?
在你描述这些的时候，我分不清这只是一个非常糟糕的夜晚？还是你见过的最糟糕的情况？
It was the worst I'd ever seen for all of those reasons. I just felt like it had the potential to be a huge catastrophe.
由于所有这些原因，这是我见过的最糟糕的情况。我只是觉得它有发生巨大灾难的可能。
A huge catastrophe means what?
巨大灾难是什么意思？
The thing that we always worry about the most and the thing that we say a lot when we are short-staffed is we are one bad car accident away from people dying. And not long ago, we had a hospital here in the area who actually had a patient die in the lobby, in the waiting room in the ER.
我们最担心的，也是我们在人手不足时常说的事情是，只要发生一起严重的车祸，就可能导致有人死亡。不久前，我们地区的一家医院实际上有病人在大厅、急诊室的候诊室里死亡。
Actually, the patient, a 41-year-old woman, became unresponsive in the waiting room and then was pronounced dead when she got into an ER bed.
事实上，那名41岁的女病人是在候诊室失去反应的，然后在被送上急诊床位时被宣布死亡。
And that's a huge-- that's a huge fear. I'm just terrified that we're going to go out there and find somebody dead.
那是一个巨大的——那是一个巨大的恐惧。我非常害怕我们会走出去发现有人死了。
She realized she just had to get more nurses to cover these cases. So she did the normal things that a charge nurse is supposed to do in that situation. First, she checked with the hospital supervisor, a.k.a. the house mom.
她意识到她必须找到更多的护士来处理这些病例。所以她做了主管护士在这种情况下应该做的正常事情。首先，她与医院主管（也就是“管家妈妈”）核实。
I don't know what we'll ever do if it's a guy because the "house mom" is really the term.
我不知道如果是位男性我们会怎么办，因为“管家妈妈”确实是这个称呼。
The house mom has the power to send somebody from elsewhere in the hospital to help out in the ER for a few hours-- nurses, lab techs who can draw blood, transport staff, anybody. So she reaches the house mom.
管家妈妈有权从医院的其他地方派人去急诊室帮忙几个小时——护士、可以抽血的化验技术员、运输人员，什么人都可以。所以她联系了管家妈妈。
And that night, there was nothing. There was no available help to be had.
而那天晚上，什么也没有。没有任何可以提供的帮助。
Second thing she tries, she asked that they page every single person who works for the ER, see if anybody who's not working will come in. Nobody says yes. Third thing, she asks if they can divert ambulances to other hospitals so they're not adding to the patient count in her emergency room. But she's told, no, computers are down at the hospital they would send patients to and they're struggling also.
她尝试的第二件事是，她要求传呼每一位在急诊室工作的人，看看是否有没上班的人愿意过来。没有人答应。第三件事，她询问是否可以将救护车转送到其他医院，这样就不会增加她急诊室的病人数量。但她被告知，不行，他们原本要送病人去的医院电脑也瘫痪了，他们也在苦苦挣扎。
Fourth thing, there's an ambulance company that the ER has a contract with and has called in, in the past, in exactly this kind of situation where they're short-staffed.
第四件事，急诊室与一家救护车公司有合同，过去在人手不足的这种情况下曾经呼叫过他们。
To help us take vital signs on patients in the lobby or just do a tour of the lobby and just check on everybody. Those are things that helps us process patients faster.
来帮助我们测量大厅里病人的生命体征，或者只是在大厅转一圈，检查一下每个人。这些事情有助于我们更快地处理病人。
But the ambulance company was too busy to send anybody. So she tried four things, all the normal things you're supposed to do. Four things failed. Was there any place else she could turn for more help? Then she got an idea, the thing that landed her in the papers. She called 911.
但那家救护车公司太忙了，派不出任何人。所以她尝试了四件事，所有她应该做的正常事情。四件事都失败了。还有其他地方可以求助吗？然后她产生了一个想法，就是让她上报纸的那件事。她打了911。
The headlines basically were, ER nurse calls 911 for help. Though, I should say, she did not actually dial the numbers 9 then 1 then 1. She has a regular phone number that you can call and just talk to the 911 dispatcher.
标题基本上是：急诊室护士打911求助。虽然我应该说，她实际上并没有拨打9然后1然后1这几个数字。她有一个普通的电话号码，你可以拨打并直接与911调度员通话。
It wasn't like a momentous decision-making process for me. It was just desperation.
对我来说，这并不是一个重大的决策过程。这只是绝望。
[BEEP]
[哔声]
Central communications, how can I help you?
中央通讯，有什么可以帮您？
Hey, this is Kelsay over at St. Mike's in the ED. I am calling to see if you guys have any available crews that can come in and help us in our lobby. We are drowning.
嘿，我是圣迈克尔急诊室的Kelsay。我打电话是想看看你们是否有空闲的机组人员可以过来帮帮我们的大厅。我们快淹死了。
OK, hang on for me one moment.
好的，请稍等我一下。
OK, yeah, I don't know what hoops I have to jump through, but my house mom is drowning as well. So I thought, I'm just going to call and see what I might be able to make happen.
好的，是的，我不知道我要跨越什么障碍，但我的管家妈妈也快撑不住了。所以我心想，我干脆打个电话看看我能做点什么。
Can I just say the thing that really strikes me is you sound so calm.
我能说真正打动我的是你的声音听起来非常冷静吗？
And that is really kind of part of the job description of being the charge nurse. And I've been like that my whole life, even as a kid. In the moment of crisis, I tend to stay pretty calm and focused and get home and cry.
这确实是作为主管护士工作职责的一部分。而且我一辈子都是这样，即使小时候也是。在危机时刻，我倾向于保持冷静和专注，回到家再哭。
Did you go home and cry at the end of this night?
那天晚上回家后你哭了吗？
That night and, yeah, though it wasn't the only time that I went home and cried during that week.
那天晚上，是的，虽然那并不是那周我唯一一次回家哭的时候。
How many patients are there?
那里有多少病人？
Right now I have, it looks like, about-- so I have about-- so in the lobby, I have two nurses for about 45 patients, which is horrible.
现在我有，看起来，大约——所以我有大约——在大厅里，我有两个护士负责大约45个病人，这太糟糕了。
And I can hear it in my voice. I can hear my alarm. Even though it sounds to the outsider that I sound like I'm really calm, I can hear little things in my voice that tell me that I'm freaking out, and I'm trying to hide it.
我能从我的声音中听出来。我能听到我的焦虑。尽管对于局外人来说，我听起来非常冷静，但我能从我的声音里听到一些细微的东西，告诉我我正在惊慌失措，而我正试图隐藏它。
Yeah, yeah, tell me what you're hearing that gives that away to you.
是啊，是啊，告诉我你听到了什么让你暴露了这一点。
The laughter, really, is the thing that gives that away to me.
笑声，真的是笑声让我暴露了这一点。
I mean, I know it's like unprecedented times, unprecedented request, but I figured it was worth a shot.
我的意思是，我知道这是史无前例的时刻，史无前例的请求，但我认为值得一试。
Right--
对——
A little nervous laugh, kind of like, I don't know what else to do. It's almost like I am-- I'm throwing myself at your mercy because I have no, I have no other options.
一点紧张的笑，有点像，我不知道该怎么办了。这几乎就像我——我把自己交给了你们的仁慈，因为我没有，我没有其他选择了。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
Kelsay. I'm a charge nurse tonight. Lucky me.
Kelsay。我今晚是主管护士。真是幸运。
OK. OK. Yeah, I'm going to see what we can do here.
好的。好的。是的，我要看看我们能做什么。
911 decides to help her out. They sent an ambulance crew with three people. The three of them work the lobby, help monitor and process patients. They're there for nearly two hours, which is enough to get Kelsay over the hump. Afterwards, when nurses around the country hear about this, they call Kelsay a shero, they reach out to her. Some of them said, thanks for the idea, call 911. I'm going to keep that one in mind just in case.
911决定帮助她。他们派了一支有三名成员的救护车队。他们三个人在大厅工作，帮助监控和处理病人。他们在那里待了近两个小时，这足以让Kelsay度过难关。事后，当全国各地的护士听说这件事时，她们称Kelsay为女英雄，她们联系她。其中一些人说，谢谢你的主意，打911。以防万一，我会记住这一招。
Did it seem heroic to you, what you did?
你做的事情对你来说看起来很英勇吗？
Not at all. Not at all. I don't see it that way. And I just saw it as solving a problem, doing my job trying to solve a problem.
一点也不。一点也不。我不这么看。我只是把它看作解决一个问题，尽我的职责去解决一个问题。
She was the charge nurse. It was on her to figure things out. She basically raised her hand when she took the job and said, I'm it, and then had to deal with everything that followed, stuff she never predicted or imagined, which is true of everybody in our show today. We have stories where people are like, oh, I'm going to be the one to fix that. And only later did they really discover, to their surprise, what that can really entail. Even when you think you see things coming, you've got it under control, that's who you are, you do not see things coming. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
她是主管护士。弄清楚事情是她的责任。她在接受这份工作时基本上举手说，我来做，然后不得不处理随之而来的一切，那些她从未预料到或想象到的事情，这对于我们今天节目中的每个人来说都是事实。我们有一些故事，人们说，哦，我来解决那个问题。直到后来他们才真正发现，令他们惊讶的是，这到底意味着什么。即使当你认为你预见到事情到来，你已经控制住了，那就是你，你并没有预见到事情的到来。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请留下来。
Act One, Every day is Father's Day. Family relationships, they get set in certain patterns that usually just harden over time. I heard somebody recently used the word "cooked" to describe their relationship with a parent. That relationship is cooked, it's done, it's not going to change. Megan Tan felt that way about her and her dad.
第一幕，每一天都是父亲节。家庭关系，它们被设定在特定的模式中，这些模式通常随着时间的推移而固化。我最近听到有人用“煮熟”这个词来形容他们与父母的关系。那种关系煮熟了，完了，不会再改变了。Megan Tan对她和她父亲的关系就有这种感觉。
For years, they'd been distant. He was super critical of her. She stopped engaging, moved across the country, stayed away. And then something happened that made Megan decide to try to uncook the relationship, to remake it with different ingredients, which is one of the things that you just can't tell how it's going to go till you try. Here's Megan.
多年来，他们一直很疏远。他非常挑剔她。她停止了互动，搬到全国的另一边，远离他。然后发生了一件事，让Megan决定尝试“解冻”这种关系，用不同的原料重新塑造它，这是你在尝试之前无法预知结果的事情之一。这是Megan。
My relationship with my father has always felt tail-chasing, like we can never get close. It just didn't work. We're pretty different. And he'll be the first to tell you how. This is a call from 2021.
我和父亲的关系一直感觉像在追逐自己的尾巴，好像我们永远无法亲近。就是行不通。我们非常不同。他会第一个告诉你我们有多不同。这是一次2021年的通话。
Yes, you're more emotional than--
是的，你比——
Than you are?
比你更情绪化？
Yeah.
是啊。
'Cause you cry out in the open.
因为你会公开哭泣。
I do cry out in the open. [CHUCKLING] What about you? When do you cry? Do you cry ever?
我的确会公开哭泣。[轻笑] 你呢？你什么时候哭？你哭过吗？
Don't compare. I don't cry. I hardly cry.
不要比较。我不哭。我几乎不哭。
Oh, why?
哦，为什么？
That's me. That's the way I was brought up.
那就是我。那就是我受到的教育方式。
"That's the way I was brought up," he says. But it's hard to get him to say more than that. It's conversations like this that remind me I'm always getting to know my father.
“那就是我受到的教育方式，”他说。但他很难说出更多。正是这样的对话提醒我，我总是在了解我的父亲。
When I was little, he didn't teach us the language he grew up speaking. So I thought one way we could become close is if I learned Mandarin Chinese. When I was a freshman in college, I spent a whole year in the library learning how to write characters, doing rote memorization, burning phrases into my brain.
我小时候，他没有教我们他从小说的语言。所以我认为我们可以亲近的一种方式就是学习普通话。大一那年，我在图书馆花了一整年时间学习写汉字，进行死记硬背，把短语刻进我的脑海里。
[SPEAKING IN MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
[SPEAKING IN MANDARIN] Happy New Year, that's common thing people [INAUDIBLE].
[说普通话] 新年快乐，这是人们常说的[听不清]。
Come on, Dad, I'm trying here.
得了吧，爸爸，我正在努力。
Over the phone, I remind him of what happened my first break home from college. We sat across the table and I showed off my new skills.
在电话里，我提醒他大一寒假回家时发生的事情。我们坐在桌子对面，我展示了我的新技能。
I wanted to learn Chinese because I was trying to understand you and trying to get closer to you. And then I studied and studied and studied. And then I came home. That was the first time you ever told me that you didn't speak Chinese.
我想学中文是因为我想了解你，想和你更亲近。然后我学啊学啊学。然后我回家了。那是你第一次告诉我你不会说中文。
Yep. Surprise.
是啊。惊喜吧。
"Surprise," he says. And, yeah, I was surprised, shocked, really. Especially when I said, [SPEAKING IN MANDARIN] and he said, I have no idea what you're saying. I was 18 years old when my dad told me for the first time he spoke Teochew. In the end, he told me I should learn Spanish instead. It's more practical in America.
“惊喜吧，”他说。是的，我很惊讶，甚至可以说震惊。特别是当我说了[说普通话]而他说，我根本不知道你在说什么。我18岁时，父亲第一次告诉我他会说潮州话。最后，他告诉我我应该改学西班牙语。它在美国更实用。
I suppose this is when I should share some warm childhood memories of my dad. But when I reach back in my memory, I don't really see him. I don't see him at my birthday parties, volleyball games, or academic award ceremonies. He was pretty closed off, icy, shuttered. I remember how he always said "no," how walking around him meant you walked softly. I remember his mood swings and how nothing I did felt like it was enough.
我想这时候我应该分享一些关于父亲的温暖童年回忆。但当我回想记忆时，我真的看不到他。我在我的生日派对、排球比赛或学术颁奖典礼上看不到他。他非常封闭、冷漠、禁闭。我记得他总是说“不”，记得在他身边走意味着你必须轻手轻脚。我记得他的情绪波动，记得我做的一切似乎都不够好。
I would tell him I got all A's. He would say, but you didn't do the dishes. I would pay for my own ballet classes. He would say, why are you wasting money on exercising?
我会告诉他我得了全A。他会说，但你没洗碗。我会自费参加芭蕾舞课。他会说，你为什么要浪费钱去锻炼？
By the time, I went to college I had accepted how things were between us. I tried not to tell him anything I cared about because I didn't think he really cared to listen. He didn't really want to know me. But we always stayed in touch, even though it was pretty surface. I would call him, check in.
到我上大学时，我已经接受了我们之间的情况。我尽量不告诉他任何我在乎的事情，因为我觉得他并不真正在乎去听。他并不真的想了解我。但我们一直保持联系，尽管只是表面上的。我会给他打电话，问候一下。
Then, in 2021, my dad sunk into a deep depression. He was in such a dark place my older sister Kristel called me. She's in Ohio. I'm all the way in LA. She didn't know what to do.
然后，在2021年，我父亲陷入了严重的抑郁症。他处于如此黑暗的状态，我姐姐Kristel给我打了电话。她在俄亥俄州。我在洛杉矶，远在天边。她不知道该怎么办。
I felt for my father. So I made him a part of my daily routine. I would call him every morning to remind him someone was thinking of him.
我为我父亲感到难过。所以我让他成为我日常生活的一部分。我每天早上都会给他打电话，提醒他有人在想着他。
In January of 2022, I call my father three times and he doesn't respond. Wednesday, nothing. Saturday, I leave a message. Monday, I leave another message.
2022年1月，我给我父亲打了三次电话，他都没有回应。周三，没有。周六，我留了言。周一，我留了另一条言。
Just as I'm putting my phone down, he calls me back. Hello? Dad? His voice is scratchy and dry. I can barely hear what he's saying. He's calling me from the floor.
就在我放下电话时，他给我回了电话。喂？爸爸？他的声音沙哑干燥。我几乎听不清他在说什么。他从地板上给我打电话。
What do you mean you're on the floor? He fell. He's been on the floor for five days. I'm panicking. I keep my dad on my phone while I call Kristel with my boyfriend's phone. She says she's rushing over and hangs up.
你说的你在地板上是什么意思？他摔倒了。他在地板上躺了五天。我惊慌失措。我一边用男友的手机给Kristel打电话，一边保持和我父亲的通话。她说她马上赶过去，然后挂了。
On the line with my dad, I keep him talking. I listen closely to his breathing. Then I hear everything unfold.
在和我父亲通话时，我让他保持说话。我仔细听着他的呼吸。然后我听到了事情的经过。
Through his phone, I hear my sister come into his apartment. I hear her call 911. I hear medics rush through the door. They ask my father a few questions.
通过他的电话，我听到我姐姐进了他的公寓。我听到她打了911。我听到医护人员冲进门。他们问了我父亲几个问题。
What's his name? Where does he live? How old is he?
他叫什么名字？他住在哪里？他多大了？
I hear a stretcher unfold. My sister picks up his phone and tells me she'll call me right back. Click.
我听到担架展开的声音。我姐姐拿起了他的电话，告诉我她马上再给我回电话。咔哒。
I call my sister and ask for updates every day. The doctors don't know why my father fell. They don't know if he had a heart attack or a stroke. My sister tells me he's barely awake. He's having a hard time talking, walking, and going to the bathroom.
我每天都给姐姐打电话询问最新情况。医生不知道我父亲为什么会摔倒。他们不知道他是心脏病发作还是中风。我姐姐告诉我他几乎醒不过来。他很难说话、走路和去洗手间。
After my dad is discharged from the hospital and checked into a rehabilitation facility, I buy a one-way plane ticket. I'm on my way back to my hometown in Ohio. My dad is 75, but when I see him for the first time after his fall, he looks like he's 90. Usually, he's a round, big belly guy. But now his skin is hanging off his face.
在我父亲从医院出院并住进康复中心后，我买了一张单程机票。我正在回俄亥俄州老家的路上。我父亲75岁了，但当我摔倒后第一次见到他时，他看起来像90岁了。通常，他是一个圆滚滚、大肚子的家伙。但现在他的皮肤挂在脸上。
His eyes are sunken in. His hair is unrecognizably long. And he has a beard. I didn't even know he could grow a beard.
他的眼睛凹陷。他的头发长得难以辨认。他还留了胡子。我甚至不知道他能长胡子。
Beside him is a walker. I quickly kiss him on the cheek and say, "Hi, Dad," pretending to be unfazed. I'm coming in all smiles. I'm the youngest in my family, you know, the one who makes the jokes, who intentionally brings an upbeat Kimmi Schmidt, Ted Lasso can-do spirit to family gatherings.
他旁边是一个助行器。我赶紧亲吻他的脸颊说，“嗨，爸爸，”假装没事。我笑着走进来。我是家里最小的，你知道，那个爱开玩笑的人，那个故意给家庭聚会带来快乐的Kimmi Schmidt、Ted Lasso那种“我能行”精神的人。
I kind of thought when I touched down in Ohio I would be the sunshine that saves my family. I would swoop in, relieve my sister, help my dad bounce back to himself, and then be back on an airplane. My dad spends a couple of weeks at the rehabilitation facility and then moves back home to his apartment.
我本以为我降落在俄亥俄州时会成为拯救家庭的阳光。我会冲进来，减轻我姐姐的负担，帮助我父亲恢复到原来的样子，然后坐飞机离开。我父亲在康复中心待了几周，然后搬回家住进了他的公寓。
I start living with him temporarily. I get him into a routine. And every morning, I have him do an exercise he loathes.
我开始和他暂时住在一起。我让他养成一个作息。每天早上，我都让他做一种他厌恶的运动。
OK, smile three times. Ready? One. Nice, OK, rest. All right, two. Big teeth, big teeth, there you go. OK, three, mm. Big, big, big, cheese, cheese, cheese. Beautiful. Smiling looks good on you, Dad.
好的，笑三次。准备好了吗？一。很好，好的，休息。好吧，二。大牙齿，大牙齿，这就对了。好的，三，嗯。大，大，大，茄子，茄子，茄子。真美。笑起来很适合你，爸爸。
I want his grin to remind him of the person he used to be, the person who moved across the world, Singapore to the US, as a 22 year old, totally alone to pursue a dream to attend college and study art. My father loved to draw. He made his living drawing and drafting streets at a civil engineering firm.
我希望他的笑容能提醒他曾经的样子，那个22岁时独自一人从新加坡搬到美国去追求梦想、上大学、学艺术的人。我父亲喜欢画画。他靠在一家土木工程公司画图和设计街道谋生。
When we were all sleeping, he'd sketch cartoons and figures on old newspapers. I'd find them in the kitchen the next morning all over the metro section. After my dad retired, he would fly home to Singapore by himself to see his family. He would cook incredible Chinese food, fill his sketchbooks with portraits, and he was always in the middle of some big biography.
当我们都在睡觉时，他会在旧报纸上画卡通和人物。第二天早上，我会在厨房里的地铁版块到处都能找到它们。我父亲退休后，会独自飞回新加坡看望他的家人。他会做美味的中国菜，把他的速写本填满肖像画，而且他总是读着一些厚重的传记。
I want to say, Dad, that's who you are and that's who you can be again. But he fights me. He says, "no" and "I can't." This becomes his default response to everything. I feel like he's the boulder and I'm Sisyphus.
我想说，爸爸，那就是你，那就是你可以成为的样子。但他反抗我。他说，“不”和“我做不到”。这成了他对一切的默认反应。我觉得他是巨石，而我是西西弗斯。
It's weird to be in my hometown for more than three days. Usually, I'm in and I'm gone. As I accompany my sister and my dad to visit doctor after doctor, I feel like I'm getting a peek into their life together.
在老家待超过三天很奇怪。通常，我来了就走。当我陪着姐姐和父亲去看一位又一位医生时，我觉得我窥探到了他们在一起的生活。
Kristel is 10 years older than me. When my parents got a divorce and sold our childhood home, she helped them sell it. She helped my father move into his apartment, connected him to his doctor when he needed one. For most of our lives, Kristel has been the one shouldering the family responsibilities I've always avoided.
Kristel比我大10岁。当我的父母离婚并卖掉我们的童年住所时，她帮助他们卖掉了它。她帮助我父亲搬进他的公寓，在他需要时为他联系医生。在我们一生中的大部分时间里，Kristel一直是那个承担我一直回避的家庭责任的人。
At one appointment, we visit my father's psychiatric nurse practitioner. After the three of us settle into her office, she directs her focus on my father. She asks him some intimate questions about his health and how he's been feeling, his mood, his motivation.
在一次预约中，我们拜访了我父亲的精神科执业护士。在我们三个在她的办公室坐定后，她将注意力集中在我父亲身上。她问了他一些关于他健康状况的私密问题，以及他的感受、情绪、动力。
He answers honestly. He tells her he has nothing to live for, that there's no purpose in his life anymore, and that he feels lonely and isolated. I sit quietly and sink into the chair. My father would never say this to us directly, which is why I'm hearing it all for the first time.
他诚实地回答。他告诉她他没有什么可活的了，他的生活中不再有目标，他感到孤独和被孤立。我静静地坐在椅子上，沉了下去。我父亲永远不会直接对我们说这些，这就是为什么我是第一次听到这一切。
A few minutes go by. And then the nurse turns to us. Because of his weakness, poor balance, cloudy thinking, and general fatigue, he can't live alone anymore, she says. She asks if he agrees. He does. But he tells her he feels guilty about burdening us. She looks at us again, smiles, and says one more thing, he should probably move in with one of you.
几分钟过去了。然后护士转向我们。她说，由于他的虚弱、平衡感差、思维不清和普遍疲劳，他不能再一个人住了。她问他是否同意。他同意了。但他告诉她他感到内疚，因为给我们造成了负担。她再次看着我们，微笑着说了最后一件事，他大概应该搬去和你们其中一人住。
Kristel and I talk it through. Dad could move in with her. But, to be honest, I don't know if that's such a good idea. She has a kid, multiple jobs. Her life is already so full, so stressful.
我和Kristel商量了一下。爸爸可以搬去和她住。但老实说，我不知道那是不是个好主意。她有一个孩子，有多份工作。她的生活已经很充实，压力很大了。
But in LA, my apartment is on the first floor. I have a walk-in shower, all the things he needs. I could do it. On my own, I decide, it has to be me. It just does.
但在洛杉矶，我的公寓在一楼。我有步入式淋浴间，所有他需要的东西。我可以做到。我自己决定，必须是我。就是必须是我。
Instead of seeing this moment as a burden, I want to see it as an opportunity. My father and I could become closer if we live together. But I need him to want this too. So at a family meeting, I put living in LA on the table to see what he says.
我不把这个时刻看作负担，而把它看作一个机会。我和我父亲住在一起可以变得更亲近。但我需要他也想要这样。所以在一个家庭会议上，我提出搬到洛杉矶，看看他怎么说。
Two big questions, stay in Ohio or move to California. It's like choose your own adventure.
两个大问题，留在俄亥俄州还是搬到加利福尼亚。这就像选择你自己的冒险。
Based on my health basis, I don't think I can do either one.
基于我的健康基础，我不认为我可以做任何一个。
That's not a part of--
那不是——的一部分
That's not an option, Dad.
那不是一个选择，爸爸。
Yeah, and if you come to California, you would be staying with me. You say, me and Megan, new roommate situation, [LAUGHS] OK? If you stay in Ohio, you would be either in a retirement facility--
是啊，如果你来加利福尼亚，你会和我住在一起。你说，我和Megan，新的室友情况，[笑] 好吗？如果你留在俄亥俄州，你要么在养老院——
Oh yeah?
噢是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's clear my dad doesn't want to commit to anything. After 10 minutes of circling around a decision, I start to get impatient. I asked my father pointedly--
很明显我爸爸不想承诺任何事情。在绕着一个决定转了10分钟后，我开始变得不耐烦。我直截了当地问我父亲——
If I said, you have to move to California and live with me, how would you feel about that?
如果我说，你必须搬到加利福尼亚和我住在一起，你会怎么想？
I feel great.
我感觉很好。
Oh, oh, great.
噢，噢，很好。
OK. All done.
好的。全完成了。
OK, great, let's choose that one. You said you'll feel great?
好的，太棒了，让我们选这个吧。你说你会感觉很好？
I like California.
我喜欢加利福尼亚。
I do too.
我也喜欢。
But--
但是——
No, no, no, I like this. Da-da-da-da.
不，不，不，我喜欢这个。哒哒哒哒。
Logistics.
后勤工作。
Oh, Dad, logistics are logistics.
噢，爸爸，后勤就是后勤。
We're in Ohio for another three weeks. Now that we're counting down the days, my father's anxiety is ramping up. He doesn't understand how he's going to get on the plane or how we're going to get out of his apartment lease. He doesn't think he has enough pants for California. Everything is impossible.
我们在俄亥俄州还要待三周。现在我们正在倒计时，我父亲的焦虑感在加剧。他不明白他要怎么上飞机，或者我们怎么从他的公寓租赁合同中脱身。他不认为他在加利福尼亚有足够的裤子。一切似乎都是不可能的。
What's our deal? To have hope. Can you have hope? Say yes. Can you have hope? Say yes. Yes.
我们的交易是什么？有希望。你能有希望吗？说是的。你能有希望吗？说是的。是的。
It's hard for me to listen to this. I sound forceful, like a sunshine bully. My dad tries to say something, but I quickly interrupt him.
我很难听这些。我听起来很强硬，像个阳光霸凌者。我爸爸试图说什么，但我很快打断了他。
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔]
Is this negative energy? What do you have to have? What do you have to have? Hope. Can you have hope?
这是负能量吗？你必须拥有什么？你必须拥有什么？希望。你能有希望吗？
Here we go again.
又来了。
Yeah. We're going to live together.
是的。我们要住在一起了。
How?
怎么做？
Step by step. We're going to make it work, OK? I need you to trust me. Remember?
一步一步来。我们要让它成功，好吗？我需要你信任我。记得吗？
Yes, trust me, your 31-year-old daughter, who has never been a caretaker before and is taking you away from everything you know.
是的，信任我，你31岁的女儿，她从来没当过护理员，而且要把你从你所知道的一切中带走。
Good morning and welcome aboard. Your flight crew this morning is Captain Oscar--
早上好，欢迎登机。今天早上的飞行机组人员是Oscar机长——
Before this, I lived alone for three years. Then my boyfriend moved in and now my dad. There are three of us in my one bedroom apartment. When we walk in, I immediately start dad-proofing the rooms. I roll up all of my colorful rugs so my dad doesn't slip and fall. In my bathroom, I install a raised toilet seat and grip bars.
在此之前，我独自一人住了三年。然后我男朋友搬进来了，现在我爸爸也来了。我的单间公寓里有三个人。当我们走进去时，我立即开始对房间进行爸爸防范。我卷起我所有的彩色地毯，以免我爸爸滑倒。在浴室里，我安装了升高的马桶座圈和扶手。
I give my father my bed and my bedroom. My boyfriend and I get the pullout bed in our dining room/office. I hide all my lingerie and sexy bathing suits.
我把我的床和卧室让给我父亲。我和男朋友睡餐厅/办公室里的折叠床。我藏起了我所有的内衣和性感的泳衣。
When my father lands in Los Angeles, he's still incredibly weak. And I'm not just his daughter. I'm also his secretary. I find him doctors and book his appointments. When he needs to pay a bill, we pay it together.
当我父亲在洛杉矶降落时，他仍然非常虚弱。我不仅仅是他的女儿。我还是他的秘书。我帮他找医生并预约。当他需要付账单时，我们一起付。
I'm also his nurse. I help him change his clothes and take showers. When he has an accident, I clean up the floors. He's having a hard time eating and I'm watching him lose weight. I monitor his appetite and cook him specific meals for breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
我也是他的护士。我帮他换衣服，帮他洗澡。当他发生意外时，我清理地板。他吃饭很困难，我看着他体重下降。我监控他的胃口，为他准备早餐、午餐和晚餐。
I've brought in a crew of people to help. There's a speech, physical, and occupational therapists and a nurse who all come to visit. An hour here, an hour there. But I'm the first person he sees in the morning and the last person he sees at night. The weight of his moment-to-moment life is fully on my shoulders and I had no idea how heavy it would be.
我找了一群人来帮忙。有语言治疗师、物理治疗师、职业治疗师和一名护士，他们都会来拜访。这里一小时，那里一小时。但我每天早上第一个见到的人是他，晚上最后一个见到的人也是他。他每时每刻生活的重担完全压在我的肩膀上，我不知道这会有多重。
He can't sit down without my help, can't take a shower without me there. Every move he makes, I'm right beside him, his shadow. Still, I try to resume my life, launch back into work, make plans with friends, go out to bars. I try to take my dog to the park, cook and clean the house like usual.
他没有我的帮助就不能坐下，没有我在旁边就不能洗澡。他走的每一步，我都紧挨着他，像他的影子。尽管如此，我还是试图恢复我的生活，重新开始工作，和朋友做计划，出去喝酒。我试图带我的狗去公园，像往常一样做饭和打扫房子。
But it's just not possible. I cancel on my friends last minute. I can't keep the house clean. And I'm constantly running late to meetings. His life is my life. It's all consuming.
但这根本不可能。我最后一分钟取消和朋友的约会。我无法保持房子清洁。我总是迟到会议。他的生活就是我的生活。这令人筋疲力尽。
But I can't tell my father that. We're together all the time. But I feel like I'm living this part of our life alone. And it's only been two weeks.
但我不能告诉我父亲。我们一直在一起。但我觉得我是在独自度过我们生命的这一部分。而且才过了两周。
I need my dad to depend on me a little less or start to move in that direction. So I try to help him. At the kitchen table, I surround us with post-it notes and colorful markers, ready to brainstorm.
我需要我爸爸稍微少依赖我一点，或者开始朝那个方向迈进。所以我试着帮他。在餐桌上，我用便利贴和彩色标记笔围住我们，准备头脑风暴。
If you can have anything, what do you want it to be?
如果你能拥有任何东西，你想要它是什么？
I'm definitely more into this future planning than he is. He's closing his eyes and starting to fall asleep.
我肯定比他更热衷于这种未来规划。他闭上眼睛，开始打瞌睡。
Dad?
爸爸？
How can you answer that question?
你怎么能回答那个问题？
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't know. Just make a goal.
我不知道。定个目标吧。
My dad once told me before I go to bed, I should envision the things I want to accomplish, that he used to do that. That's how he came to America. And that's always worked for me. But I can't convince him to make any goals. So I pick up a marker and start doing it for him.
我爸爸曾经告诉我，睡觉前，我应该设想我想完成的事情，他过去常这样做。这就是他来到美国的原因。这对我一直很有效。但我无法说服他制定任何目标。所以我拿起一支笔，开始替他做。
You want to become independent?
你想变得独立吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
I'm so blinded by my own determination to move him forward. Maybe he does need to sleep. But that's not what I'm thinking right now. I'm afraid. I write down a few more goals like walk without my walker, change clothes by myself.
我被我自己的决心蒙蔽了，想要推动他前进。也许他真的需要睡觉。但这不是我现在想的。我害怕。我写下了更多目标，比如不用助行器走路，自己换衣服。
How about cooking for myself and my daughter? How about that? That's a good one. What's another one, Dad? Dad, are you there?
自己为自己和女儿做饭怎么样？怎么样？那是个好主意。还有什么别的，爸爸？爸爸，你在吗？
His eyes are closed. He's tapped out and so am I. No one ever told me my father would become independent again. No nurse told me he would or wouldn't walk without his walker. No doctors told me he would or wouldn't drive.
他的眼睛闭着。他放弃了，我也是。从来没有人告诉我我父亲会再次变得独立。没有护士告诉我他会不会不用助行器走路。没有医生告诉我他会不会开车。
I don't know what's realistic, which means I'm in my own ideal world and I'm just winging it . I'm making up these goals. I want to imagine a better life for him. And he's improving, little by little, day by day.
我不知道什么是现实的，这意味着我生活在自己的理想世界里，我只是在摸着石头过河。我在编造这些目标。我想为他想象更美好的生活。他正在好转，一点一点，一天一天。
He's able to sit down and stand up on his own. But I notice he's not making his bed. He's able to walk more confidently, but he's not going outside. He's able to stay awake longer, but he's not being social.
他能自己坐下和站起来。但我注意到他没有铺床。他能更自信地走路，但他不出去。他能保持更长时间的清醒，但他不进行社交。
He spends hours in the middle of the day lying in his bed doing nothing. That's when I'm the most frustrated with him. I storm into his room or I cry to myself in a corner. Exhausted by my own emotions, I call up a Buddhist friend who just encourages me to just let him be and to love him exactly as he is, to respect his life if he leaves his bedroom or not.
他每天花几个小时躺在床上什么也不做。那时我对他的挫败感最强。我冲进他的房间，或者在角落里自己哭泣。被自己的情绪耗尽后，我给一个佛教朋友打了电话，她鼓励我让他顺其自然，完全按照他本来的样子爱他，尊重他是否离开卧室的生活。
I start writing that phrase down every day for myself. "I will respect my father's life. I will love him exactly as he is," something I've never written down before. And this becomes my new goal, to hold my tongue, to say less.
我开始每天为自己写下那句话。“我会尊重我父亲的生活。我会完全按照他本来的样子爱他，”这是我以前从未写下过的。这成了我的新目标，管住自己的舌头，少说话。
It's hard. I slip up all the time, especially when it comes to his medication. Dad, did you take your medication yet? It's 10:00. You were supposed to take it at 9:30.
这很难。我总是犯错，尤其是在他的药物方面。爸爸，你吃药了吗？10点了。你本应该9点半吃的。
Sometimes I catch myself. You're doing that thing again. You're making it sound like he's messing up. But some days, I can't stop.
有时我抓住了自己。你又在做那件事了。你让事情听起来好像他在搞砸。但有些日子，我无法停止。
Did you drink your water today? I interrogate him. Are you sure? Your water bottle looks full.
你今天喝水了吗？我审问他。你确定？你的水瓶看起来是满的。
I'm starting to realize it's the small stuff I say every day, the little things that can chip away at him the most. Because that's what he did to me. When he gets all A's, I focus on how he didn't do the dishes. It takes me a while.
我开始意识到，我每天说的小事，那些小事情最容易削弱他。因为那就是他对我不做的事情。当他得全A时，我关注的是他怎么没洗碗。我花了一段时间。
Eventually, I do get better. When it's 2:00 in the afternoon and I notice that my dad has been lying in bed for the past three hours, I go into his room and I ask if he wants to go for a walk. He says "no" and I just say "OK." I let him be.
最终，我确实好转了。当下午2点，我注意到我爸爸过去三个小时一直躺在床上，我走进他的房间，问他想不想散步。他说“不”，我只是说“好的”。我让他顺其自然。
It's June now. We're three months in and I've been practicing saying less. We get on the phone with Kristel.
现在是六月了。我们已经住了三个月了，我一直在练习少说点话。我们和Kristel通了电话。
Well, give her an update. How are you doing, Dad?
好了，给她更新一下。你怎么样，爸爸？
What update?
什么更新？
How's work?
工作怎么样？
What's going on?
发生了什么？
Huh?
嗯？
It's fine.
没事。
Huh?
嗯？
Yeah.
是啊。
I mean, work-work I'm talking about, not your housework.
我是说工作，不是你的家务。
Yeah, it's fine. [CHUCKLING]
是的，没事。[轻笑]
Can you tell he's stronger? [CHUCKLING]
你能看出他变强壮了吗？[轻笑]
Yeah.
是的。
My appetite got better.
我的胃口好转了。
That's one of the first times I've heard my father recognize he's progressing out loud.
这是我第一次听到我父亲大声承认他正在进步。
What? That's awesome. And Megan's feeding you good food, I hear?
什么？太棒了。听说Megan给你吃好东西了？
I guess.
我想是吧。
[GIGGLING]
[咯咯笑]
I'm laughing because I know he's joking. In the past, I might have gotten defensive. But now I know him better.
我笑是因为我知道他在开玩笑。过去，我可能会变得防卫。但现在我更了解他了。
And he's helping around the house. He helped me organize my cables yesterday. Tell them what you did yesterday.
而且他在帮着做家务。他昨天帮我整理了电缆。告诉他们你昨天做了什么。
We went to the park.
我们去了公园。
What did we have to eat, Dad?
我们吃了什么，爸爸？
Snacks, crackers.
零食，饼干。
Crackers?
饼干？
Yeah, we're running out of food right now.
是啊，我们现在的食物快没了。
We're not running out of food. We just need to go to grocery store like every family on a Sunday.
我们的食物没有没。我们只需要像每个家庭在周日一样去杂货店。
Is he really worried we're running out of food? I'm trying to get better at listening to him, like really listening. I don't want to brush him off or just tell him everything is fine. So I ask him directly about his worries and fears. He lists off a few things. He's worried about his car, his clothes, where all the stuff from his apartment went.
他真的在担心我们的食物会没吗？我正试图学着更好地听他说，真正地听。我不想对他置之不理，或者只是告诉他一切都好。所以我直接问他的担忧和恐惧。他列举了一些事情。他担心他的车、他的衣服，他公寓里的东西都去哪了。
Do you have anything else you're worried about?
你还有什么担心的吗？
A lot of things I'm worried about.
我担心的事很多。
What are you worried about?
你在担心什么？
Money.
钱。
What would make you not worried about money?
什么会让你不担心钱？
More money.
更多的钱。
[GIGGLING]
[咯咯笑]
As I'm loosening up, he's loosening up too. And I can tell he's coming into himself again. During breakfast when we're sitting at the dining room table, conversations that used to be dominated by his health status are replaced with mundane talks about whatever, which is great.
随着我变得放松，他也变得放松了。我能看出他重新找回了自己。早餐时，当我们坐在餐桌旁时，那些曾经被他的健康状况占据的谈话，被关于任何事情的琐碎谈话所取代，这太棒了。
Did you have any dreams?
你有做梦吗？
Yeah, all kinds of dreams.
有，各种各样的梦。
Oh, like what?
哦，比如什么？
I'm trying to solve a problem.
我试图解决一个问题。
What was the problem?
是什么问题？
A math problem.
一道数学题。
A math problem?
一道数学题？
Yeah.
是啊。
That was the dream?
那是梦的内容？
Yeah, I screwed up. I don't remember.
是啊，我搞砸了。我不记得了。
Don't remember the math problem?
不记得那道数学题了？
Yeah. What about you?
是啊。你呢？
No dreams.
没做梦。
No dreams? Nothing?
没梦到？什么都没有？
No.
没有。
So now we talk about all kinds of things. But I hadn't asked him about how he thought it was going. Was I pushing him too hard? How was he feeling? Then, a few weeks ago, one afternoon, he shuffles into my office. I sit him in a chair and we get into it. I ask him, those first few weeks in LA, what was he thinking?
所以现在我们谈论各种各样的事情。但我没问他他觉得进展如何。我是否对他要求太严？他感觉如何？然后，几周前的一个下午，他挪动着脚步走进我的办公室。我让他坐在椅子上，我们开始了谈话。我问他，在洛杉矶的那最初几周，他在想什么？
Those days, I was in a state of shock.
那些天，我处于震惊状态。
You were in a state of shock?
你处于震惊状态？
Trauma.
创伤。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah. Having to change planes, change house, moving here and moving there. It was just dizzy.
是啊。不得不换飞机，换房子，搬到这里又搬到那里。真是头晕目眩。
Dizzy, his mind was dizzy. When I asked my father specifically about whether or not making goals was helpful, he tells me they weren't.
头晕目眩，他的大脑头晕目眩。当我专门问我父亲制定目标是否有帮助时，他告诉我没有。
Even though you have good intentions, I just cannot see the outcome. Every day I ask myself, what am I-- what am I going to do? My mind doesn't open. Just block. It's a block. I had nothing to look forward to. That's the way I felt, yeah.
即使你有良好的意图，我也无法看到结果。每天我都问自己，我——我要做什么？我的大脑不开窍。只是卡住了。这是一个障碍。我没有任何期待。这就是我的感受，是的。
That's the way you felt then?
那是你当时的感受？
Yeah, until I overcome my injuries, I didn't feel confident to be able to do all these things. And I don't think anybody will help me do this.
是的，直到我克服伤痛，我都没有信心能做所有这些事情。而且我不认为有人会帮我做这些。
Why?
为什么？
Because that's the way life is. Being dependent on somebody to do all these things, it's not easy, yeah.
因为生活就是这样。依赖别人做所有这些事情，并不容易，是的。
Do you feel like I'm pushing you?
你觉得我在逼你吗？
No, no, essentially, you're trying to encourage me, trying to get me set in the positive direction.
不，不，本质上，你是在试图鼓励我，试图让我朝着积极的方向前进。
It's not annoying?
不烦人吗？
It could be annoying, but I don't have much to say.
可能会烦人，但我没太多可说的。
What do you mean?
你什么意思？
Well, I know you're trying to do your best. Yeah. And I try to follow you, yeah. 'Cause I know you think much about me.
嗯，我知道你在尽力。是的。我试着跟着你，是的。因为我知道你在为我着想。
This isn't the first time my dad has told me that he sees me and everything I've been doing. But every time he says it, it still gets to me. Me doing my best is enough.
这不是我爸爸第一次告诉我他看到了我，看到了我一直在做的一切。但每次他说这些话时，它仍然会触动我。我尽力了，这就够了。
After I fell, I felt that you were more concerned about my life than ever before, yeah.
我摔倒后，我感觉你比以往任何时候都更关心我的生活，是的。
Whereas before, we were just living separately, right?
而之前，我们只是分开生活，对吗？
Yeah, living separately and after I fell, you get to know more, know more about me, I believe. I get to know more about your workings, how you feel. What is this? This is good. And your determination, determination to help me. Not a surprise, but just not a shock.
是的，分开生活，我摔倒后，你开始更多地了解我，了解更多关于我的一切，我相信。我也开始更多地了解你的工作方式，你的感受。这是什么？这很好。还有你的决心，帮助我的决心。不是惊喜，只是不震惊。
It could be a shock. Was it a surprise?
这可能是一种震惊。这是一种惊喜吗？
Yeah, it was a surprise. Yeah.
是的，这是一种惊喜。是的。
Why was it a surprise?
为什么这是一种惊喜？
Because I never thought that you really do care.
因为我从没想过你真的在乎。
It takes me a while to process what he's saying. I never knew he felt like I never cared. Because I've always cared. But maybe he's right. Maybe I didn't care as much as I care now.
我花了一段时间来消化他在说什么。我从不知道他觉得我从不在乎。因为我一直很在乎。但也许他是对的。也许我没有像现在这样在乎。
Megan Tan is the host of Snooze, a podcast from LAist Studios. Her story was produced by Laura Starcheski. Coming up, the surprising power of making a spreadsheet full of profanities. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Megan Tan是LAist Studios播客Snooze的主持人。她的故事由Laura Starcheski制作。接下来，制作一个全是脏话的电子表格的惊人力量。这是芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后的内容，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "You're It," stories of the people who step up and say, I will take care of this, I've got this, and the very, very unexpected places that can lead them.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“就是你”，讲述那些挺身而出说，我来处理这个，我有办法，以及这可能导致的非常、非常意想不到的地方的故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show, Act Two, Game of Phones. So over the last few years, one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has been checking in with somebody who decided that they were going to be it, like, forever ago and wears the mantle well. She's a school principal, likes being in charge, was great about the whole thing of the buck stopping with her. She is very consistent about it, except for one choice she made that Chana did not understand. Here she is.
我们已经进入了节目的第二幕，第二幕，手机游戏。在过去的几年里，我们的一位制片人Chana Joffe-Walt一直在跟进某个人，她很久以前就决定她要成为那个“就是你”的人，并且很好地承担了这个角色。她是一位中学校长，喜欢负责，非常善于处理“责任到她为止”的事情。她对此非常一致，除了她做的一个Chana不理解的选择。她在这里。
A school principal is a pretty classic "you're it" job. It's all you. When the school needs new math books, a new curriculum, a new budget, you're it. A pipe broke and now the science classroom is flooded, you're it. Students got into a fight at lunch, seven teachers called in sick today and now there are 14 minutes to rearrange the entire schedule and communicated to everyone involved, all you.
中学校长是一个非常典型的“就是你”的工作。全靠你。当学校需要新的数学书、新的课程、新的预算时，就是你。管子坏了，科学教室被淹了，就是你。学生在午餐时打架，七个老师今天请病假，现在有14分钟重新安排整个时间表并告知所有相关人员，全是你。
Because of this, the job tends to attract a certain type of person, a person who believes they can or should or needs to be the one called on in any given moment. Often, but not always, this is also a person who is quick to color code, has contingency plans for everything, and loves a system. You'll find variations. You've got your brilliant visionary types and the parking rules people, the person whose task lists are alphabetical, and the person who is more playing it by ear and talks about holding space.
因此，这份工作往往会吸引特定类型的人，一个相信自己能、应该或者需要在任何特定时刻被呼叫的人。通常，但不总是，这同时也是一个热衷于颜色编码、对一切都有应急计划并热爱系统的人。你会发现各种变体。你有才华横溢的远见型，有关注停车规则的人，任务清单按字母顺序排列的人，还有那些更倾向于随机应变并谈论“保持空间”的人。
Dr. Teresa Hill is somehow a little bit of all of these people. The first time I tried to describe her to someone else, I found myself saying, she's just such a principal. When I first talked to her, Dr. Hill had recently become Arizona Principal of the Year. I'd heard of Teacher of the Year. I didn't know Principal of the Year was a thing, but it is. And in 2021, Dr. Hill was the one who was picked.
Teresa Hill博士不知怎么地就是这些人的一点混合体。我第一次尝试向别人描述她时，我发现自己在说，她就是那么一个校长。我第一次和她交谈时，Hill博士刚刚成为亚利桑那州年度校长。我听说过年度教师。我不知道还有年度校长这回事，但确实有。2021年，Hill博士是被选中的人。
Yeah, no, it was just a phone call. I was in my office. It was a summer. There wasn't a lot going on and received the call, you know, congratulations, you are the Arizona Principal of the Year.
是啊，不，那只是一个电话。我在我的办公室。那是夏天。没发生什么事，收到了电话，你知道，祝贺你，你是亚利桑那州年度校长。
Why do you think you won?
你认为你为什么赢了？
Oh, who knows?
噢，谁知道呢？
I do. That was a fake-out question. I know. Dr. Hill's assistant principal nominated her. You're actually supposed to apply yourself. But the assistant principal knew Dr. Hill wouldn't actually do it. So she got the ball rolling, writing, quote, "Dr. Hill has built the culture at Walden Grove High School from the ground up."
我知道。那是一个假问题。我知道。Hill博士的副校长提名了她。实际上你应该自己申请。但副校长知道Hill博士实际上不会那么做。所以她开启了流程，写道，引用：“Hill博士从零开始建立了Walden Grove高中的文化。”
It's one of those schools that's friendly and warm. People feel excited about what they do. A few months after Dr. Hill was elevated to Principal of the Year, that's when she made a choice that seemed so unlike her, the opposite of everything she is.
这是那种友好而温暖的学校之一。人们对他们所做的事情感到兴奋。在Hill博士被提升为年度校长几个月后，她做了一个看起来与她很不相符的选择，与她所代表的一切背道而驰。
That story begins in August 2021. And you remember this time-- COVID, then schools reopening, there were teacher shortages, parents angry about masks and having to keep their kids home. And when I saw Dr. Hill facing the chaos and vitriol of that miserable period of time, I thought, oh, just watch this woman own this mess. We are about to see all the wizardry of principalness brought to bear on the situation. She's going to rein this right in.
那个故事始于2021年8月。你记得那个时期——新冠疫情，然后学校重新开放，教师短缺，家长对口罩感到愤怒并不得不让他们的孩子呆在家里。当我看到Hill博士面对那段悲惨时期的混乱和愤怒时，我想，哦，看着这个女人掌控这个烂摊子。我们即将看到校长的一切魔法都被带到了这个局势中。她会很好地掌控这一切。
Here's what things looked like at Dr. Hill's school. The county had mandated that students had to quarantine if they were exposed to COVID at school and weren't vaccinated. So Dr. Hill enforced this mandate.
以下是Hill博士学校当时的情况。县政府要求学生如果在学校接触过新冠病毒且未接种疫苗就必须隔离。所以Hill博士执行了这一要求。
Parents pushed back. One group of parents came to her school and refused to leave the lobby after one of their kids had to quarantine. They were there for hours. They were arrested. They filmed themselves being arrested, posted it online, and the videos made headlines. And after that, Dr. Hill's office administrator said there were angry voicemail messages on the school phone.
家长进行了抵制。一群家长来到她的学校，在他们的一个孩子必须隔离后拒绝离开大厅。他们在那儿待了几个小时。他们被捕了。他们拍摄了自己被捕的过程，发布在网上，这些视频上了头条。在那之后，Hill博士的办公室管理员说学校电话上有愤怒的语音留言。
And I went to her and said, hey, I need you to send me those messages. And she just shook her head and she had tears in her eyes. And she was like, you don't want to hear these messages. I told her it's OK. I just said, I understand, I know. I know they're not good. I just, I need them. So just send them to me. It's OK.
我去找她，说，嘿，我需要你把这些留言发给我。她只是摇了摇头，眼里含着泪水。她就像，你不想听这些留言。我告诉她没关系。我只是说，我明白，我知道。我知道它们不好。我只是，我需要它们。所以发给我吧。没关系的。
Why did you need them?
你为什么需要它们？
Well, everything that I did always was from a perspective of, like, I'm not going to make you do something that I'm not going to do myself. And I wasn't going to put that on her to have to sort through, you know what I mean? And that's kind of the way that I dealt with anything as a principal. It's like, I'm the leader of the school and I need to make sure that I'm taking care of things.
嗯，我所做的一切总是出于一种视角，就像，我不会让你做我不会做的事情。我不会把那种负担放在她身上让她去处理，你知道我的意思吗？这就是我处理作为校长任何事情的方式。就像，我是学校的领导者，我需要确保我在处理这些事情。
Principal Hill assumed the voicemails were about the videos that were circulating online, blaming her for enforcing the county quarantine rules. So angry messages on the school voicemail went straight to the bottom of her to do list.
Hill校长以为这些语音留言是关于网上流传的视频，责怪她执行县里的隔离规定。所以学校语音信箱上的愤怒留言直接到了她待办事项列表的最底端。
And I went about my day and did all the normal things of what I would do where, you know, I'm out supervising for lunch and supervising before school, between classes, you know, going into classes, whatever, just doing my normal thing. And then it wasn't until the end of the day once the buses have left and kids-- and teachers are kind of leaving. And then I started listening to them.
我继续我的一天，做了所有我平常会做的事情，你知道，我在午餐时督导，在学校前、课间督导，你知道，走进教室，无论什么，只是做我的日常工作。直到一天结束，校车离开了，孩子们——老师们也准备离开了。然后我开始听它们。
I hope your principal, your district, your high school, every one of you fucking morons gets sued into oblivion.
我希望你的校长、你的学区、你的高中，你们每一个该死的白痴都被起诉到遗忘状态。
That was the first one. I want to say, if you're sensitive to profanity, this doesn't let up. Principal Hill kept listening.
那是第一条。我想说，如果你对脏话敏感，这不会停下来。Hill校长继续听着。
You are committing war crimes against the people of the United States. You guys are shameful, disgusting, vile, evil. And you better check yourself before Christ.
你们正在对美国人民犯下战争罪。你们这些家伙是可耻的、令人作呕的、卑鄙的、邪恶的。你最好在基督面前检视自己。
Shame on you. You guys definitely without a doubt suck ass.
为你感到羞耻。你们这些家伙绝对毫无疑问烂透了。
Now, in the first few, I'm not really affected personally, I guess. You know what I mean? Like, I can hear people are mad. I can hear that they're venting.
现在，在最初的几条里，我想我并没有真正受到个人影响。你知道我的意思吗？就像，我能听出人们很愤怒。我能听出他们在发泄。
Like, whatever, I can deal with all that. I'm a high school principal. I deal with all kinds of conflict, right? It's not the end of the world. I'm not here to make everybody love me. No big deal. But, definitely, when the fourth one comes, then things get real.
就像，无所谓，我能处理所有这些。我是高中校长。我处理各种冲突，对吧？这不是世界末日。我不是为了让每个人都爱我。没什么大不了的。但是，绝对地，当第四条来的时候，事情就变得真实了。
Yes, hi, if you could just let Teresa Hall-- I'm sorry, Teresa Hill, the principal of Walden Grove High School, know that America is watching her and if she could do everybody in this country a favor and disappear, maybe spin on a sandpaper dildo, maybe run backwards through a cornfield, maybe eat the end of a shotgun. Any of those things would be acceptable. So tell her she better watch her six.
是的，嗨，如果你能让Teresa Hall——对不起，Teresa Hill，Walden Grove高中的校长知道美国在看着她，如果她能帮这个国家的每个人一个忙并消失，也许去磨砂膏假阳具上转圈，也许向后跑过玉米地，也许吃下猎枪的枪口。这些事情中的任何一件都是可以接受的。所以告诉她最好小心她的背后。
Dr. Hill paused. She was sitting alone in her office, door closed, listening on speakerphone. And she'd been clicking through the messages-- next message, next message-- until this one.
Hill博士停顿了一下。她独自坐在办公室里，门关着，通过扬声器在听。她一直在点开留言——下一条，下一条——直到这一条。
I'd never received anything like that as a principal, as a teacher. I mean like, whoa, what the heck, you know?
作为校长，作为老师，我从未收到过这样的东西。我的意思是，哇，这是什么鬼，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah. Yeah, "eat the end of a shotgun," maybe you should "eat the end of a shotgun."
是啊。是啊，“吃下猎枪的枪口”，也许你应该“吃下猎枪的枪口”。
She slowly repeated the words of the messages to herself. And then, she got back to work.
她慢慢地对自己重复留言中的话。然后，她回到工作岗位。
OK, I think I need, I need to save these. They were telling me that they were going to sue me. And I thought, you know what? I want to make sure that I have this on record. And so as I was listening to the first-- to them for the first time, I was also transcribing them.
好的，我想我需要，我需要保存这些。他们告诉我他们要起诉我。我想，你知道吗？我要确保我有记录。所以当我第一次听它们的时候，我也在转录它们。
You started transcribing word for word what people were saying?
你开始逐字转录人们在说什么？
Yeah.
是啊。
You're bullies, cowards, and deniers of freedom.
你们是恶霸、懦夫，自由的否认者。
She typed "cowards, deniers of freedom." There are 40 messages like these.
她打出“懦夫，自由的否认者”。有40条这样的留言。
Shame, shame, shame.
羞耻，羞耻，羞耻。
She was playing them on speakerphone and her assistant principal overheard, came in to help Dr. Hill transcribe in case she needed these messages for something in the future, maybe as evidence, she thought.
她在扬声器上播放它们，副校长听到了，进来帮助Hill博士转录，以防万一她未来需要这些留言做点什么，也许作为证据，她想。
How about we end up outside your guys' houses? We're not going to protest the school. We'll go directly to your bloody fucking homes.
如果我们去你们家里怎么样？我们不会抗议学校。我们将直接去你们血淋淋的该死的家。
"Bloody fucking homes," Dr. Hill types.
“血淋淋的该死的家，”Hill博士打字。
As a person who has transcribed a lot of audio because of my job, it takes a really long time. And if you are trying to get it word for word, you have to go back over and over again.
作为一个因为工作原因转录过很多音频的人，这需要很长时间。如果你想逐字逐句，你必须一遍又一遍地回去。
Yeah, I mean, there were times where I was-- we would look at each other and I was like, did they say this or did they say that? And she would say, I heard this. I'm like, oh, I heard this. So let's play it again. And we would play it again.
是啊，我的意思是，有几次我——我们会看着对方，我就像，他们说这个了吗还是说那个？她会说，我听到了这个。我说，噢，我听到了这个。所以让我们再放一遍。我们会再放一遍。
To be like, did he say, you definitely are a sick ass or you suck ass?
就像，他说的是，你绝对是个烂透了的人还是你烂透了？
Right. Oh yeah, mm-hmm.
对。噢，是的，嗯哼。
Oh my god.
天啊。
Yeah. I was typing away. I would stop. I would go back, type again. And like, unfortunately, I couldn't just go back a little bit. So I literally, when I went to restart, I would have to listen to the message from the very beginning all the way through again. I mean, man, it was brutal.
是啊。我在努力打字。我会停下来。我会回去，再打一次。不幸的是，我不能只退回一点点。所以我真的，当我重新开始时，我必须从头到尾再听一遍留言。我的意思是，老兄，这太残酷了。
But she kept going all the way through the end. She could get this under control. She could create a useful document. And I'm not talking about a simple transcript.
但她一直坚持到底。她能控制这一切。她能创建一个有用的文档。我说的不是简单的转录。
Tell me about the format. This is a spreadsheet. Why did you choose to do it this way?
告诉我格式。这是一个电子表格。你为什么选择这样做？
I guess I'm a math teacher and I like spreadsheets more than I like Word. [LAUGHS]
我想我是个数学老师，我比Word更喜欢电子表格。[笑]
It has columns. You say the message number, the time, the date, the phone number of the person.
它有列。你标出留言号码、时间、日期、那个人的电话号码。
Yeah.
是啊。
It feels to me like, oh, when I saw it, I was like, of course she's a principal. She has organized, clear information. Did it feel like you were interacting with it in the way that you might a school budget or--
我感觉就像，哦，当我看到它时，我就想，她当然是个校长。她有组织、清晰的信息。你是否觉得你在以处理学校预算的方式与之互动，或者——
Yeah, I mean, I even highlighted so you could see, this is a direct threat. This is an implied threat. I just felt like it was a lot more organized this way. And I think that's part of why I did it. It's something I can control, getting the phone number, writing down what is exactly said. I think that transcribing actually, it helped me, like, detach myself from what was being said and make it more like a job. I don't know if that makes any sense.
是啊，我的意思是，我甚至做了高亮，这样你能看到，这是一个直接威胁。这是一个暗示的威胁。我只是觉得它用这种方式更有条理。我想这就是我这样做的部分原因。这是我可以控制的事情，获取电话号码，写下确切说了什么。我想转录实际上，它帮助我，就像，让我从所说的事情中抽离出来，让它更像是一份工作。我不知道这有没有意义。
That makes so much sense. That makes so much sense. Yeah.
这太有意义了。这太有意义了。是啊。
Principal Hill sent her spreadsheet to the superintendent, noting the threats that may still need investigating by police, helpfully color coded by degree of danger, the same way she may have shared, say, a color chart that allows you to assess and visualize student achievement. It's not an obvious choice to respond this way. But everything she did in response to these messages felt so in line with who she is and how she operates.
Hill校长把她的电子表格发给了学监，指出警察可能还需要调查这些威胁，并根据危险程度贴心地进行了颜色编码，就像她可能会分享，比如说，一份允许你评估和可视化学生成绩的颜色图表一样。以这种方式回应并不是一个显而易见的选择。但她回应这些留言所做的一切都与她的个性和运作方式非常一致。
She managed it. She contained the problem and shielded everyone else from unnecessary distress. She didn't share the messages with anyone else-- her colleagues, her husband. She told her family she'd gotten some threats and to be on alert for strange cars.
她管理了它。她控制了问题，并保护了其他人免受不必要的痛苦。她没有与任何人分享这些留言——她的同事、她的丈夫。她告诉她的家人她收到了一些威胁，要注意奇怪的车。
And she began parking in the back of the school and entering that way. She told me she imagined if someone was waiting to snipe her out when she arrived for work in the morning, they'd be sitting by the front door. She said this casually, not like a person who was panicked or scared, but a person who was taking the appropriate steps to deal with the problem. It was handled.
她开始把车停在学校后面，并从那里进入。她告诉我她想象如果有人在她早上上班时等着狙击她，他们会坐在前门。她随口说了这些，不是像一个惊慌失措或害怕的人，而是像一个正在采取适当步骤处理问题的人。它被处理了。
And then we get to the choice that I did not understand. Principal Hill quit in the middle of the school year. Just six months after she was named Principal of the Year, she left her job.
然后我们来到了我不理解的选择。Hill校长在学年中途辞职了。就在她被评为年度校长六个月后，她离开了她的工作。
She didn't leave immediately after the harassment. She kept going to work for a couple of months. But the voicemails started to get to her.
她没有在骚扰后立即离开。她继续工作了几个月。但语音留言开始影响她了。
The thing about listening to something over and over is that it stays with you. That was the accidental side effect of transcribing these messages. Principal Hill says the words became ingrained in her head. And she would find herself in a meeting or supervising lunch outside and they'd pop back up.
听东西听多了，它就会留在你心里。那是转录这些留言的意外副作用。Hill校长说这些话在她脑海里根深蒂固了。她会发现自己在开会或者在外面监督午餐时，它们就会冒出来。
You know, I'd find myself in the courtyard, like, not talking to anybody, you know? Just like in my own little world sitting there by myself, not interacting with kids and doing the things that I like to do.
你知道，我会发现自己在庭院里，就像，不跟任何人说话，你知道吗？就像在自己的小世界里独自坐着，不与孩子互动，也不做我喜欢做的事情。
I'm a pretty positive person. And I like to keep things light and move forward. And this was like heavy on me.
我是一个很积极的人。我喜欢让事情轻松并继续前进。但这对我来说感觉很沉重。
You couldn't move forward.
你无法继续前进。
At the time, I couldn't, no. And I had a hard time. Because you know deep down how you feel. You don't feel good. And, yet, it's not healthy for anyone in your organization to know how you feel. So you slap on a smile--
当时，我不能，没有。我很难过。因为你知道内心深处你的感觉。你感觉不好。然而，让组织里的任何人知道你的感受对谁都不健康。所以你脸上挂上微笑——
Wait, why? Why?
等等，为什么？为什么？
You know, you put on a happy face and--
你知道，你挂上一张快乐的脸，然后——
What is that? That's some principal thing that people can't know how you feel?
那是什么？那是某种校长的事情，人们不能知道你的感受？
Yeah, I guess so. I mean, people want leaders who are strong but who aren't emotional. And, you know, I don't-- I don't ever want to put my own burdens and my own challenges on my people.
是啊，我想是吧。我的意思是，人们想要强大的领导者，但不是情绪化的。而且，你知道，我不想——我永远不想把我的负担和挑战放在我的人民身上。
Dr. Hill is so good at keeping what she feels to herself that even after we talked about this for hours, I still didn't understand why she had to leave, why this was the thing that she couldn't shake off. But then, months after she left her job, Dr. Hill gave testimony in court. And she spoke candidly in public about her experience of all this for the first time.
Hill博士非常善于把自己的感受藏在心里，以至于即使我们讨论了几个小时，我仍然不明白她为什么必须离开，为什么这是她无法摆脱的事情。但在她离开工作岗位几个月后，Hill博士在法庭上作了证。她第一次公开坦率地谈论了她对这一切的经历。
The parents who wouldn't leave her school were charged with trespassing. There was a whole trial. They were found guilty.
那些不愿离开她学校的家长被指控非法入侵。进行了整个审判。他们被判有罪。
And then the judge asked Dr. Hill if she wanted to say anything. Did she want to share the effect this had on her? And she did. She talked about her fear. And this time, she wasn't all casual in describing avoiding the front entrance of the school.
然后法官问Hill博士她想说什么吗。她想分享这给她带来的影响吗？她说了。她谈到了她的恐惧。这一次，在描述避开学校正门时，她一点也不随意。
I couldn't go through the front of the school in this day and age with shootings and attacks on public officials. If you listen to the messages and you heard their anger and their blood pressure raised, I feared for my safety and I feared for the safety of my family. This has negatively impacted me physically.
在当今枪击和攻击公职人员的时代，我无法穿过学校的前门。如果你听了那些留言，听到了他们的愤怒和他们血压的升高，我为我的安全感到恐惧，我为我的家人的安全感到恐惧。这在身体上对我产生了负面影响。
I've had health problems because of this. It's impacted me mentally. And, unfortunately, the biggest impact is it affected me professionally. Never in my 29 years as an educator would I think of leaving my school halfway through the year.
因为这个，我的健康出现了问题。它在精神上影响了我。而且，不幸的是，最大的影响是它在专业上影响了我。在我29年的教学生涯中，我从来没想过会在一年中途离开学校。
She said to the judge, you have to understand what I had to listen to.
她对法官说，你必须了解我不得不听的内容。
I don't want to cuss, but I think I need you to understand here. If it's OK, I can quote some of those messages that were left for me.
我不想骂人，但我认为我需要你了解这里。如果可以的话，我可以引用一些留给我的留言。
The judge gives permission to cuss. And Dr. Hill, who had prepared nothing, has nothing written down, begins repeating the messages verbatim. It's like she's been waiting to let them out.
法官准许骂人。Hill博士，什么都没准备，没有写下任何东西，开始逐字重复留言。就像她一直等着把它们发泄出来。
I was called a fucking cunt. I was told to sit and spin on a sandpaper dildo. I was told to disappear. I was told to eat the end of a shotgun.
我被骂是个该死的妓女。我被告知坐上去在磨砂膏假阳具上转。我被告知消失。我被告知吃下猎枪的枪口。
I was told not to go out in public. I was told, we're not coming to the school, we're coming to your house. And I lived in fear for four months after that.
我被告知不要公开露面。我被告知，我们不来学校，我们来你家。在那之后，我在恐惧中生活了四个月。
A friend of mine, an assistant principal for decades now, told me he still remembers his mentor explaining early on that the job of a school leader is never inflict pain on an institution. The job is to absorb pain for the institution. It must be confusing to be any kind of public official right now, trying to absorb the pain of the last few years.
我的一个朋友，一位当了几十年副校长的朋友，告诉我他仍然记得他的导师在早期解释说，学校领导的工作从来不是给机构造成痛苦。工作是为机构吸收痛苦。现在做任何类型的公职人员一定很困惑，试图吸收过去几年的痛苦。
How many principals or election officials or public health officials or prime ministers of countries have scrambled to respond to a public that is rageful by doing what they know how to do, by throwing PowerPoints at people, by holding public hearings, printing out color charts, only to finally understand that all the vitriol and misinformation was always going to be too enormous for any one person to absorb. Principal Hill shielded everyone else from distress until it was only hers.
有多少校长、选举官员、公共卫生官员或国家总理为了回应愤怒的公众，通过做他们知道怎么做的事情，通过向人们扔PPT，通过举行公开听证会，打印彩色图表，却最终发现所有的愤怒和错误信息对于任何一个人来说都太大而无法吸收。Hill校长保护了其他人免受困扰，直到它变成了她一个人的困扰。
But it wasn't just the words. It was the isolation that I felt with it. I felt like I was all alone in dealing with the situation. That is what made me say, I can't do this anymore.
但这不仅仅是言语。这是我感受到的孤独感。我觉得在处理这种情况下我孤身一人。这就是让我说，我不能再这样做了的原因。
So many of these voicemails are asking for you to resign.
这些语音留言中有很多要求你辞职。
Yeah.
是啊。
So then when you did, did it feel like, oh, I don't want to give them what they wanted?
所以当你辞职时，感觉就像，哦，我不想给他们想要的？
Of course. Of course. But I had to really dig deep and do what was best for me.
当然。当然。但我必须深入挖掘，做最适合我的事情。
What was best for her was the one choice that was completely out of character, something far from her principalness and all her familiar moves. She decided not to be "it" anymore.
最适合她的是那个完全不符合性格的选择，远离她的校长作风和所有她熟悉的举动。她决定不再是“那个角色”了。
Chana Joffe-Walt is a producer on our show.
Chana Joffe-Walt是我们节目的制片人。
Today's program was produced by Miki Meek and Bethel Habte. People who put together today's show include Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, David Kestenbaum, Valerie Kipnis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reimond, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Lilly Sullivan, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由Miki Meek和Bethel Habte制作。今天节目制作人员包括Chris Benderev、Sean Cole、Aviva DeKornfeld、Cassie Howley、David Kestenbaum、Valerie Kipnis、Katherine Rae Mondo、Alaa Mostafa、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reimond、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala、Lilly Sullivan、Matt Tierney和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Ravenna Koenig, Mike Sowiski, and Regina Grossman, and the NASSP. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's all kinds of other stuff-- lists of favorite shows, videos, tons of things there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Ravenna Koenig、Mike Sowiski、Regina Grossman以及NASSP。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费播放我们超过750集的存档。此外，还有各种各样的其他东西——最喜欢的节目列表、视频、大量的内容都在那。再一次，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he called me at 2:00 AM today, 2:00 AM, woke me up to tell me he's been having trouble sleeping lately. Could I maybe sing him a lullaby?
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他今天凌晨2点给我打了电话，凌晨2点，把我叫醒告诉我他最近失眠。我能给他唱首摇篮曲吗？
I mean, I know it's like unprecedented times, unprecedented requests, but I figured it was worth a shot.
我的意思是，我知道这是史无前例的时刻，史无前例的请求，但我认为值得一试。
I'm Ira Glass back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。